the way you get respect as a woman is by
being feminine there's nothing we can be
equal and very very different I'm not
saying that when there's not equality
but you've confused equality with the
same you can be equal with completely
different things you can have a bishop
and a knight on a chessboard they're
equal in terms of points but they do
different things right a woman can have
equal respect to a man if she is very
good at being a woman and a man gets
respect for being very good at being a
man when a woman decides she wants to
act like a man or a man wants to act
like a woman that's where all gets
[__] up we're trying to pretend it's
the same it's not the same men and women
are good at different things we have
different strengths different weaknesses
there's nothing wrong with accepting
that there's nothing wrong with saying
I'm a woman I'm good at X he's a man
who's good at why then we work together
as a team we have a beautiful family
we're happy forever